right put your feet up for my perfect TV
dinners like all chefs good food is my
life and for me TV dinners are all about
recipes that are fuss-free quick and
easy to make so however busy you are you
can always knock up brilliant food my TV
dinners need minimal shopping and rely
on the staple ingredients you already
have in the cupboard so you can enjoy
incredible dishes whenever you want
starting with my delicious mushroom and
leek pasta this fantastic fast and
simple pasta dish made with everyday
ingredients just goes to prove you can
eat good food whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta while the water
comes to the boil start the sauce by
slicing mushrooms first off fingers one
in front two behind up and down then add
olive oil to a hot frying pan I want
that nice color on the mushrooms off the
heat lifting 10 seconds and when you
toss something really important you get
all the ingredients to the end of the
pan push down and pull that that nor is
this metal water coming out of the
mushrooms next finely chopped a fat
clove of garlic
[Music]
don't prepare your leeks just take your
knife and then go down through the
center turn it over and again into
quarters see all that opening up and
then just rinse the top of that your of
any potential dirt or sand it just
breaks up into nice little courses add
all that leek those mushrooms beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of the
water inside the leech as it cooks down
all the waters gone need to set about
really nice intense flavor
Darla's got nice and crispy now we're
gonna add a touch of chicken stock in
there Isana sheets drop the sheets in to
the water lasagna sheets are an unusual
choice for a dish like this but they
work brilliantly although any type of
pasta you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan that stops any
pasta actually sticking to the bottom
the pan chicken start the reduce down by
half and it's almost dead lays the
bottom the pan basically washed all that
wonderful flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up the ball and let it simmer for 3
to 4 minutes now the secret of the pasta
is just taking it out a little early so
you got that nice texture hold up the
sheet and just nip it and you can feel
your fingers in the center it's ready
turn the sauce down and lay these
beautiful sheets on the Sonya into that
sauce just going to turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce finish with
chopped fresh tarragon I said delicious
herb he goes brilliant new world
mushrooms and leeks let that sit almost
sort of infuse to serve I'm making a
quick bruschetta by toasting fresh
ciabatta bread to nice slices drizzle
that in oliver
a bit of garlic just rub the bread the
crust as well
crust this is what really takes that
garlic now pan for the bread with touch
of olive oil as it starts to smoke bread
in
[Music]
but look at the pastor now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve
on a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then I'll take my pasta just
twist it and let it sit on top that
tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on and that's the beauty about
something so simple they can be done in
20 minutes with everyday ingredients a
stunning pasta dish
having easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you always make
great tasting food at the drop of a hat
with foolproof pasta recipes up your
sleeve you'll always be able to knock up
a fantastic lunch or supper there are
three more of my super fast pasta dishes
that are bursting with flavor and
cooking minutes
kicking off with Vitaly with ricotta
pancetta and peas
[Music]
start by fine lardons in a large pan
these smoke chunks of bacon have a
delicious deep salty flavor that makes
them perfectly pasta
when'll are gonna start to brown add
finely chopped garlic and turn off the
heat
next at farfalle to boiling salted water
named after the Italian for butterflies
this bowtie che pasta has a large
service area great for sticking to
sauces just before the pasta is ready
add frozen piece of the boiling pasta
water
then when the pastor and the pay's are
cooked drain and add to the Laden's and
the garlic
spooning creme fraiche
[Music]
and dot with lumps of creamy ricotta
cheese
season
then serve
ready in just 12 minutes pork belly with
ricotta pancetta and peas
a delicious quick and easy supper that's
ready when you are
[Music]
my next pronto pasta dish is tagliatelle
with quick sausage meat bolognaise
[Music]
first Bull DRI tagged Italian salted
water these long thin ribbons of pasta
come curled up in nests and take around
10 minutes to cook
then add olive oil to hot pan
a fry finely chopped onion thinly sliced
garlic and sweat until soft
[Music]
next remove the meat from your sausages
by cutting open their skins and crumble
into the pan
Fennell or Sicilian sausages are perfect
for this dish but any flavored sausage
will do
[Music]
when the meat is browned add half cherry
tomatoes season
[Music]
and add a few spoonfuls of the pasta
cooking water as the starch thickens the
sauce and helps us stick to the pasta
drain detector telly and add to the
sausage meat sauce
finish with freshly grated Parmesan
[Music]
perfect when you're really busy but
still want great tasting food fast
my amazing tagliatelle with quick
sausage meat bolognaise my final path
dish that's ready in the flesh and packs
a real flavor punch this spaghetti with
chili sardines and Oregon Oh
[Music]
first for the crunchy topping heat olive
oil in a frying pan add chopped garlic
[Music]
and breadcrumbs
[Music]
cook over medium heat until the
breadcrumbs of gold
season and drain on kitchen paper
for the source add the oil from your
sardines to a hot pan if I finally dies
chilly
and top garlic
next cook dry spaghetti in boiling water
then chopped in sardines into chunks I'm
add to the chilli and garlic 10 sardines
are a Brindley versatile ingredients to
have in your cupboard packed with
protein full of super healthy omega-3
oils and delicious next drain your pasta
and combined with the sardine chilli and
garlic mixture
that leaves a fresh oregano and mix in
handfuls of rocket
deserve part hi and top with the crispy
garlic bread crumbs
[Music]
ready in under 15 minutes spaghetti with
chili sardines and oregano healthy party
and full of flavor perfect pasta in
moments
[Applause]
whether you're rushing to put your feet
up in front of the telly and need
something fast and tasty for the family
or simply want something delicious to
enjoy these are three amazing pasta
recipes you can learn by heart
and cook in minutes beautiful
[Music]
now here are five more of my essential
cooking tips starting with how to cook
an ingredient that's perfect for a quick
and easy TV dinner chicken breasts
this has to be the most popular part of
the chicken now very versatile
incredibly tender very lean hardly any
fat whatsoever
the secret is cooking it without it
becoming dry the first thing is to
season it properly both sides two
tablespoons of olive oil get the pan
nice and hot the secret now is to get a
really nice color on the skin a really
nice color no color no flavor skin side
down tilt the pan so it cooks the back
of the chicken breast where it's really
nice and round and very flat let the pan
do the work
chicken breast Norma takes between sort
of 1012 minutes to cook properly now
we've got the color on the skin the
skins nice and crispy because the glaze
the pan the glaze is masala now masala
is a sweet fortified Italian wine you
can also use white wine masala in flambe
burn off the alcohol which gets rid of
that really sort of harsh alcoholic
flavor roll the chicken around the
masala the days in the pan basically
means washing the pan and lifting off
all that flavours stuck to the bottom of
the frying pan and putting it into the
sauce now chicken stock bring that out
to the boil and let it simmer for three
to four minutes
[Music]
very important to leave the chicken
breast skin side up the skins nice and
crispy and it's important and the
chicken cooks from underneath as it
starts cooking it absorbs to stop so in
the center of chicken stays nice and
moist now the stock of the masala is
reduced down who have the confidence to
allow it to almost disappear and look
the combination between the masala in
the chicken stock was quite sweet so
finishes the chicken with this really
nice delicious glaze on top and there
you go a delicious succulent chicken
breast with the most amazing flavor some
skin phenomenal soups make stunningly
simple meals my tip for adding
incredible depth of flavor is to always
keep your leftover parmesan rind store
them in the freezer then add to the pan
as the soup cooks and leave to infuse
then remove before serving it's less
waste and more taste
another tip to take homemade soup to the
next level whisking cubes of cold butter
just before serving to get a glossy
velvety texture and a beautifully rich
taste another fantastic standard for a
fuss free weekend eat is the classic
baked potato my tip for a great crispy
skin is to use salt to your advantage
simply add it to the outside before
cooking and the salt will draw out the
moisture in the oven as it bakes a touch
of salt gives you an amazingly crisp
skin on chicken and fish - as well as
highlighting the flavor home roasted
nuts make a delicious TV snack my tip
for peeling them with ease is to simply
toast them in the oven for about 10
minutes wrapping a tea towel and rub
until the skins are removed perfect
sprinkle with sea salt and so with a
glass of wine
this is my ultimate cookery course a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
coming up I'll be showing you my amazing
sweet corn fritters that such a
delicious recipe but first the key to
with them at my ultimate TV dinners is
having a well-stocked store covered and
even with the basics like tin sardines
tomatoes pasta or rice it always pays to
know how to buy the best next up my
shopping guide to all things pasta
when it comes to the sacred Italian
staple you'll be hard-pressed to find
anyone who knows more than past the
supremo Antonio sack Imani and I Buster
so much do you did at least once a day
he's been selling perfect pasta in
London Soho for over 35 years and eating
great pasta for a lifetime
we make the best ice in the world Italy
takes away the past in Italy and the
people died that's it for a good very
good pasta you need to use radiance you
need a good edge and very good flour and
that's it this is a durum wheat flour
look at that is so soft
then she cooks so quick couple minute in
the boiling water
this tin like this couple minute is good
this shop is no is no big enough to
store all the type of pasta and this is
the famous target Tony al bronzer this
is penny different shape is called
fusilli or a kata also Traviata
Antonio's right there's a mind-blowing
array of incredible pasta types that are
great to keep in your store cupboard
here's my quick guide to some of the
different shapes and sizes and how to
use them smell shapes like a Fellini a
perfect for making simple stews and
soups more substantial and add an extra
texture to dishes like the classic
italian pasta soup minestrone
short tubes like penne are great for
thick cream or tomato-based sauces as
the rigid edges hold more sauce for an
incredibly flavor-packed mouth for long
and thin like the store covers essential
spaghetti the classic shape was invented
in Naples but every Italian region has
his own spaghetti dish from bolognese to
carbonara or my favorite alle vongole
which is spaghetti with delicious
steamed clams flat noodles shape strands
like fettuccine are perfect with a
simple drizzle of olive oil or in rich
buttery dishes as a little sauce goes a
long way coating the pasta evenly
stopping the strands from sticking
together then pass the sheets not just
grateful lasagnas but amazing roll into
tubes and fill to make delicious Karen
lonely or used in quick Supper dishes
like my mushroom and link pasta finally
speciality pastas like this spaghetti
made with squid ink as delicately sweet
taste and an amazing jet black color
great for when you want a delicious
dinner that's a little bit different
whatever shame you go for always look
out for the pastas that have been
bronzed cut it means the dough was
pressed or a bronze cutting dye which
has a subtle rough texture which helps
the sauce stick as well as all the dry
types pasta also comes fresh which is
brilliant for TV dinners because it
cooks super quick and tastes incredible
too in this job we make pasta every day
look at that that's good is sad to eat
this pasta is really really yellow cuz
we use good quality legs you can spend
the eggs they come trip is so good so
fresh you can you eat it raw like done I
last in the fridge to three days you can
even freeze it and I
whether fresh or dried pasta so
versatile and quick to cook is the
perfect TV dinner
so go out stock up on new shapes and
you'll soon be turning out dishes that
would make pasta Pro Antonia very proud
it looks so nice so good so every you
know that's it
we will lead busy lives but that doesn't
mean you have to compromise when it
comes to cooking great food for me the
secret is having recipes you can depend
on and a store cover full of stable
ingredients that can be transformed into
quick delicious dinners on demand so
shop smart stock up and whether you're
feeding two or twenty you'll always be
ready to cook up something incredible my
next tasty dish uses simple and cheap
store cupboard ingredients with stunning
results and takes minutes to make sweet
corn fritters and yogurt dip it's
brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweet corn somewhere so long as I had to
make the most amazing fritter
[Music]
first off the mixture take your flour
sieve
really important to sieve the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there just before you get to the end
I want to put half a teaspoon of baking
powder the baking powder gives the
mixture some lift in and just sip that
through such a salt and pepper next an
egg about four tablespoons of milk and
give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle of olive
oil in there that helps to relax the
mixture we set in make sure you got into
all those lumps so they'll want a nice
smooth almost like a cake mixture okay
next take the seeds out of a chili to
lower the heat well with chili so give
it a really good shake
[Music]
tap them out slice in half into quarter
and each quarter in half and chop
through it's a really nice quick way of
slicing a chili into the mixture spring
onion take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail
slice in an angle so little bit of
texture running through the mixture want
that nice crunch in coriander just slice
through nice and gently
you get that in there next to sweet corn
now drain it from the tin and just Pat
it dry so doesn't make the mixture too
wet give that a nice mix
you can see now I've got 2/3 ingredients
and 1/3 of a mixture to bind together as
a cigarette fretta so you're you're
biting into excitement and not sort of
dough pan on olive oil in nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion in space the
fittest evenly around the pan in a
clockwise direction so you always know
which one to turn first
just put the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit okay
pilot knife just check now food with a
color and turn over beautiful now for
the chili yogurt dressing be seed and
finely chop a red chili and add to a pot
of natural yogurt
and then some fresh line finish with
chopped coriander coriander in give that
a nice mix up a chili just lifts it the
lime gives it a nice tang enos the
fritters they smell amazing
now with the sauce tastes fantastic that
such a delicious recipe using ITIN a
sweet corn from your cupboard amazing
[Music]
followed by ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
you literally be cooking yourself into a
better chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the App Store for details go on get
cooking